du nord au sud de charleville mézières à
nice de 7 à cherbourg je pars la
rencontre des français pour les écouter
parler j'ai aménagé une vieille caravane
et j'invite des gens rencontrés dans la
rue quelques minutes auparavant à
poursuivre leur conversation devant nous
en toute liberté
ça va être un été internet le moment
têtu avoir pu se rompre et quelqu'un je
suis sûr que j arrête pas de dire à
jeudi au goût comme toi mais on est
complètement leurs boisés
elle vous on se demande pourquoi mais on
sent d'ailleurs il n'ya pas que les
équipes le mari aussi c'est sacré et
match récente publie c'est parce que et
savent tenir une personne arrêtée là
pour ce jeu là tiens compliqué de dormir
avec quelqu'un vous a fait du bruit ça
bouge
et moi ça amélie mer c'est pas dur c'est
la guerre je bouge et ça c'est sûr je
pourrais faire carrière chez amoureuse
en fait tu as cité comme un bébé
dès que je me suis mis en couple tout
les fillonistes ça fait 40 ans je suis
là je ne partirai jamais je suis en fait
la vie belle elle change mais les écrits
champions un couple en mal ou d'un
revendeur
on a eu l'habitude de vivre en famille
dans la famille dans le quartier
raconte-t-il
et la ville